I'm Giuseppe,
I'm Italian
and I started dancing 10 years ago
casually for an Italian choreographer,
Virgilio Sieni,
that wanted to know more about
visually impaired people
concerning the movement.
And from there I started my journey
through many different types of dance,
but always along the lines of Virgilio's style.
Then, after this journey,
5 or 6 years later,
I've met many different artists
and also dance companies
that work with disabled people,
through international exchanges.
Like the (Europe Beyond Access) Laboratory that happened here
in Maastricht.
From that moment, I started working
in other countries
outside Italy, with other choreographers.
The first solo I did with Virgilio
was called "Atlante del bianco".
It was a study on how colours
can influence the movement
and how a movement can illustrate a colour.
The performance had short transitions,
the room and the space were all white
yet sometimes they were flooded by colour.
Depending on the colors, the movement
and the scene could change completely.
It is important that we can be
dancers and artists in general
at a professional level.
For disabled people, it is very important
to be able to choose freely
what we want to do.
Other examples are to have the opportunity
of going to school,
of enriching ourselves culturally,
in practice,
and everything that can help us
to become a professional
in dance and the arts.
This is what I want...
If possible, this would be the mission.